I mean it was a real conversation and
that's something that we wanted to
include in the documentary like we have
a couple fights in this movie like we
really didn't want we want to include it
all just because like what couple
doesn't have these struggles but we have
different struggles I'm gonna say
expecting Amy oh my gosh girl you show
it all I put it watch three hours I feel
like I know you I watched all three
episodes but why did you want to
showcase your journey going into
motherhood well honestly I think it's I
think it's the same reason I wanted to
partner with Tampax which is like
because I don't have like something's
wrong with me where I don't have the
thing that I want is like you know make
myself look perfect or whatever like I
act like people relate to me and I want
to be as open as possible so that you
know I can help help women you know feel
better about themselves because we're
all going through you know we all we all
go that we all get our periods we all
like all this stuff that we're not
supposed to talk about um and you know
pregnancy we're supposed to make it look
easy and I I just like really reject
that so um so I wanted people to you
know hopefully feel better and educate
um you know other women about what might
happen if they get pregnant you
definitely do just that and who would
have known that I mean we definitely saw
a glimpse on your Instagram about you
being sick throughout your pregnancy
yeah many you showcase it all in this
documentary and I love the the way that
you and Chris are basically you know
self filming the whole thing uh-huh
but then we also see aspects of it that
you know gene had quite the scare he had
a kidney scare so how is little gene
doing now and his kidneys yeah thanks
for asking um well you know one of the
the hardest moments I think of my whole
pregnancy was was when the doctor asked
to turn the camera off and that's every
mother and parent's worst nightmare is
finding out that something's wrong
luckily like in the whole time they were
they thought something's wrong his
kidneys but you know there's that scene
in the in the hospital after where they
do an ultrasound they just go kidneys
are fine and we were like what you know
like that didn't even seem like a
possibility so um thank you for asking
but yeah he's he's totally healthy and
we're like you know so grateful you guys
have created the cutest kid I mean I
just no you just look at these here's
some videos that y'all post and him
reading the reviews from me he was very
just like super into it it was like dang
you know dad yeah I mean they really
mean people say like they'll do they'll
they what they're watching they'll do
what you do and he really that his dad
sits across writer it's a paper when
he's eating and so that's you he reads
the paper looking you saying are you
feeling my goal is to never complain
about being a parent you see I love
seeing the beautiful bond between you
and Chris because thank you thing that's
so just it's beautifully displayed in
expecting Amy in the documentary series
and and of course you guys face them to
tough conversations as a couple
especially when it comes to the content
and your stand up facts so how did you
getting on to the same page with your
husband about including him and some of
your act
I mean um it was a real conversation and
that's something that we wanted to
include in the documentary like we we
have a couple fights in this movie like
we really didn't want we want to include
it all just because like what couple
doesn't have these struggles but we have
different struggles um you know him
being diagnosed with autism while we
were filming was pregnant we we like we
wanted to share every aspect I'm not
trying to make ourselves look look
better than we really are like I'm not
necessarily proud of every moment that's
in this documentary of myself and its
really interesting to film yourself
fighting every couple should do that
because you learn a lot you think I'm
like oh my god I'm so right and I watch
it and I'm like oh I really like could
have been a lot better in that moment um
oh in terms of sharing you know stamp my
stand up and talking about our
relationship it's it was something for
him to adjust you and I still of course
like I asked him like is this okay
um and he's just like yeah like share it
all but you know it takes some adjusting
to you having your partner like the next
day share intimate details of your
marriage
so yeah or beautiful pieces of art that
you've drawn of one another museum needs
to be framed up in the house if it isn't
already to be in the Met I actually like
I of course like want it you know over
our bed just it's but we got two really
great place with it and he like like
laughed so hard whenever whenever we
watch that part well we were like you
know editing I think when things open
back up you guys should make a date
night of it you know go out do a little
paint line and paint yeah not good self
portrait of him honey
that's right you know I didn't even
think of that some ideas I've got some
ideas what time in quarantine are you
mostly starting to drink right now
it's very classy I love it you guys are
working so well together not only in
your marriage and as parents now but you
know you've got Amy Schumer learns to
cook you guys are renewed for a second
season so what's she gonna be whipping
up in the kitchen this time girls oh my
god this season you really learned that
I have not learned anything um we like
we were really excited you know we were
kind of thinking if we do get another
season what would we do so we you know
we've been making lists and like highly
you know I'm in charge of the drinks so
of course I've been testing those at
home um but you know it's it's like an
interesting time to have a television
show and it's not you know we tape it
and then it airs like a month later
something so it
some you know it's an interesting kind
of a television show where you know we
want to highlight everything that's
going on you know aside from the
pandemic we're also like very involved
in in the black lives matter movement
and moving that forward and so you know
it's a it's a weird it's a weird time to
have a TV show but it's a good
opportunity to get to use your voice
yeah and also just spend extra QT with
with Chris and with Jean yeah that is
that is the one silver lining to
everything going on is you know getting
to spend extra time with my family which
is like you know I was supposed to be
shooting every day a TV show right now
so I feel lucky I feel like I have the
time to protest and I feel like I have
the time to be with my family right yeah
and speaking of family you have been
very open about wanting to increase the
size of your family you were open with
your grueling IVF treatments and you
know freezing embryos and things for and
you you had a successful run and again
it's a story that you've wanted to share
so yeah well I would say um you know
it's you know success its measured it's
it's pretty subjective
we got one normal embryo which you know
some people would look at that is not
successful I were really excited that we
got one it hopefully hoping it works
we're gonna put trying to increase our
family on hold just with everything
going on it like a pandemic doesn't it
just to me doesn't feel like the time
that I want to be thrusting myself or
anyone else and you know in a medical
environment if we can avoid it how would
you explain to someone to insert a
tampon oh my god um you probably oh just
put it in there yeah you kind of I don't
even know it's been such a delight
chatting with you today and and you know
hearing about your partnership that
you've got going on I just wanna end on
that know can you create and cuz you
kind of talked about it again at the
beginning but your product who are
involved in right now
with encouraging women to educate
themselves about their bodies well I
mean I've been pretty open about this
for a while but I just feel like you
know
Tampax and I had the exact same goals in
mine which is to take the shame and all
the myths away from women's periods
you know it's we're half the population
and we get our periods for however many
days we each personally get it a month
and there's so little education about it
and there's so much stigma we're not
supposed to talk about it and you know
they only have only require sex
education classes in 29 states and only
22 of those states are any sort of
medical confirmation you know in
scientific studies so it's like and I
don't know about you like my sex ed
classes I didn't leave there knowing how
to put a tampon in confidently and so
you know I am just really excited that
to have this opportunity to help educate
women and try and just take some of the
shame out of our period you know
[Music]